so right here we've got 3 to the a power
or 8th power i guess is i don't want to
confuse it with the number 8 3 to the a
power is equal to the fifth root
of 3 squared and what we need to figure
out is what would a be equal to let's
solve for a and i encourage you right
now to pause this video and try it on
your own
well if you have a fifth root right over
here one thing that you might be tempted
to do to undo the fifth root is to raise
it to the fifth power and of course we
can't just raise one side of an equation
to the fifth power whatever we do to one
side we have to do the other side if we
want this to still be equal
so let's raise both sides of this
equation
to the fifth power
raise both sides to the 5th power
now this left hand side we just have to
remember a little bit of our exponent
properties 3a to the fifth power and if
we want to just remind ourselves where
that comes from that's the same thing as
3 to the a
times 3 to the a
times 3 to the a times 3 to the a times
3 to the a well what's that going to be
equal to that's going to be 3 to the
a plus a plus a plus a plus a power
which is the same thing as 3 to the 5
a power so the exponent property here is
if you raise a base to some exponent and
then raise that whole thing to another
exponent that's the equivalent of
raising the base to an exponent that is
the product of these two exponents so we
could rewrite this left hand side as
3 to the
5 a power
3 to the 5 a power is going to be equal
to well if you take something that's a
fifth root and you raise it to the fifth
power then you're just left with what
you had under the radical that's going
to be equal to 3 squared
so now things become a lot clearer 3 to
the 5a needs to be equal to 3 squared
or another way of thinking about we have
the same base on both sides so this
exponent needs to be equal to this
exponent right over there or we could
write that five times a
needs to be equal to two
and of course now we can just divide
both sides by five and we get a
is equal to two-fifths two
over
two
over five and this is an interesting
result and what's neat about this
example it kind of shows you the
motivation for how we define
rational exponents so let's just put
this back in into the original
expression we've just said or we've just
solved for a and we've gotten that three
to the two fifths power to the two and
actually let me color code it a little
bit because i think that'll be
interesting 3 to the 2
over 5 power
3 to the 2 over 5 power is equal to
is equal to the fifth root
notice the fifth root
so the denominator here that's the root
so the fifth root
of three
squared
three squared so if you take this base
three you square it but then you take
the fifth root of that that's the same
thing as raising it to the two-fifths
power notice take this three take it to
the second power and then you find the
fifth root of it or we could if you use
this property that we just saw right
over here you could rewrite you could
rewrite this this is the same thing
this is the same thing as
squared
3 squared and then you raise that
and then you raise that to the one-fifth
power we saw that property at play over
here you could just multiply these two
exponents you'd get three to the two
fifths power and that's the same thing
as three squared and then find the fifth
root of it three squared and then you're
essentially finding the fifth root of it